décision n'est pas encore définitive
c'est en tout cas notre volonté parce
qu'on est conscient qu'il faut un
minimum d'activités pour que les
associations puissent respecter la
promesse qu'elles ont faite à leurs
membres à leurs adhérents au mois de
septembre qu'elle n'est pas remboursé
aussi les cotisations qu'elles ont
aujourd'hui en caisse et il faut qu'à
minima à - au moins pour 50 % de leur
activité elles puissent proposer ce
service aux adhérents et on sait aussi
combien c'est important pour nos jeunes
aujourd'hui de pouvoir aller à l'école
de pouvoir participer avoir une activité
sportive et culturelle dans notre pays
donc cette décision elle sera définitive
en fonction de l'évolution sanitaire
bien sûr l'évolution sanitaire et nous
sommes en train de travailler avec les
associations sur un protocole qu'ils
respecteraient le nom brassage un
brassage minimum des enfants pour leur
permettre la réouverture pour les
publics mineurs dès qu'il sera possible
au mois de décembre
et justement les enfants ont besoin de
faire du sport est-ce que c'était
véritablement une bonne décision de les
priver de toutes ces heures de sport en
club pendant confinement on va dire que
c'était une mise en pause de l'activité
associative parce qu'il fallait
travailler sur ce nouveau protocole de
l'on mélange des publics on sait que les
associations ne fonctionne pas comme les
écoles ou comme le périscolaire avec des
notions de classe de groupe class c'est
à ça qu'il faudra qu'on arrive vraiment
là très rapidement dans les prochaines
dans les prochains jours pour qu'on
puisse soumettre ce nouveau protocole au
conseil national de défense et voir si
on peut acter cette reprise pour les
mineurs est ce que le monde du sport
amateur qui est bien touché fortement
par ce confinement est ce qu'il est en
danger aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'état et avec les annonces
d'hier de 400 millions d'euros de
mesures financières une annonce vraiment
très conséquente pour le monde du sport
nous espérons pouvoir venir en soutien
vraiment des fédérations des
associations qui malheureusement ne
peuvent pas offrir l'éventail
d'activités à tous les adhérents
aujourd'hui 15 millions d'euros seront
débloqués pour des petites associations
gérées par des bénévoles 20 millions
d'euros pour les fédérations qui ont
perdu des licenciés et puis 100 millions
d'euros qui en 2021 permettront à
beaucoup d'adultes d'enfants qui n'ont
peut-être plus les moyens ont plus envie
de revenir en club et bien d'avoir cette
incitation financière à y retourner
grâce à ce passeport porté par le
mouvement sportif et l'état dernière
question sur le sport professionnel
notamment le football professionnel en
france dont le modèle économique est
économique est actuellement un peu en
danger à cause des
la diffusion télévisée le président de
la république l'a dit ce n'est pas à
l'état de régler ce problème vous
confirmez
oui malgré les deux mesures très
attendues par l'écosystème sportif 110
millions d'euros débloqués pour
compenser les jauger les huit clos
aujourd'hui
et puis surtout une mesure très attendue
l'exonération de charges
qu'est ce qu'on sait que ces clubs
doivent continuer à payer des joueurs
des sportifs qui doivent pouvoir rester
en activité se confronter s'entraîner
donc des salaires qui sortent avec des
zéros recettes en face aujourd'hui
effectivement l'état n'a pas vocation à
remplacer un contrat de droits télé
aucunement on doit y veiller être
attentif à ce que les deux parties
aujourd'hui proposé négocié mais en tout
cas nous devons être là nous l'état pour
faire en sorte que les activités des
clubs puissent se tenir
il y a la possibilité de continuer à
faire du sport qu'on est un sportif de
haut niveau aux professionnels il faut
donner les moyens aux employeurs de
pouvoir assurer les salaires
merci beaucoup roxana maracineanu
d'avoir répondu à mes pieds
[Musique]